der schock sitzt tief snowden hat uns
mit seinen enthüllungen die augen
geöffnet
der glaube an die freiheit im world wide
web ist erschüttert pioniere des
internets wie der brite tim berners-lee
melden sich besorgt zu wort das internet
das wir kennen ist bedroht
der deutsche blogger sascha lobo löst
eine medien debatte aus das internet ist
kaputt
sogar angela merkel macht sich ernsthaft
sorgen das internet soll eine verheißung
bleiben
der ökonom schuldig kessler hat ein buch
geschrieben über das vordringen des
internets in alle lebensbereiche
was denkt ein digital native wie er über
die tatsache der überwachung im netz
märz nicht überrascht und vergessens
grund warum tempel gar nicht so groß ist
dass man einen wir unbewusst mit dann
krachend jeder krieg gegen wir überwacht
und im grunde ist ein internet optimist
aber wo viel licht ist ist auch schatten
je mehr wir online sind desto mehr
verlieren wir unsere privatsphäre firmen
wie google oder facebook kennen uns
genau wissen wie wir ticken wovon wir
uns ernähren was wir lesen was wir hören
was wir denken weil sie unsere innersten
wünsche kennen steuern sie unser
verhalten
das nennt das eine diktatur diese
ökonomische diktatur und weniger
politische und ökonomische diktatur
besteht darin dass europa an dass über
dieses grund suchen verhalten
entscheidet die wache wo man wie gern in
kauf nimmt man sogar sagen es ist die
perfekte diktatur leben wir also
freiwillig und bester laune im digitalen
panoptikum dem perfekten gefängnis mit
totalem einblick für staaten und
konzerne könnten wir nicht die segnung
des internets nutzen und den zugriff der
datensammler kleinhalten möglichkeit
besteht sich und darin selektiv mini tat
zur verfügung stehe oder nicht zur
verfügung steht
als familien tätig oder alternative
suchmaschine besuchen es ist mein job
bei facebook
es ist mini und ob er überhaupt ins
internet gehen oder digitale die
gesellschaft desto stärker auch die
sympathien für ein leben auf fleisch
er meint dass es bald eine offline
bewegung gibt
ähnlich wie die nachhaltigkeits bewegung
menschen werden ohne smartphones ohne
digitale fesseln leben wollen und
wahrscheinlich wird es sogar solche
geben die gegen computer und algorithmen
kämpfen
das gab es schon mal so ähnlich damals
ging es gegen webstühle und maschinen
im moment noch möglichkeit bestimmen wir
beim internet-nutzer valley
datensammlungen thema schwiegen die
ganze akzeptieren und gerade schaut
einfach das waren die fragen nicht
diskutiert es irgendwelche politische
akteure die entscheid für ist rafinha
entscheiden häufig gar nicht machen
online offline
es wäre doch wünschenswert auch in
zukunft das beste aus beiden welten
leben zu können